>>> AFTER A LONG WAIT, PARENTS
COULD START VACCINATING YOUNGER
CHILDREN AS SOON AS NEXT WEEK.
FDA ADVISORS VOTING IN FAVOR OF
SMALLER PFIZER DOSES FOR KIDS
AGES 5 TO 11.
IT COULD BE A KEY STEP IN
SLOWING DOWN THE PANDEMIC AS
WINTER GETS CLOSER BUT WITH 28
MILLION KIDS SOON TO BE
ELIGIBLE, THE QUESTION REALLY IS
HOW MANY PARENTS WILL GET ON
BOARD WITH THIS?
LET'S DISCUSS WITH ANTHONY
FAUCI.
DOCTOR, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US THIS
EVENING.
VACCINATIONS FOR CHILDREN 5 TO
11 YEARS OLD COULD BE APPROVED
IN A MATTER OF DAYS.
PARENTS HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT.
HERE IS A BIG ONE.
THE DOSING.
THE 5 TO 11-YEAR-OLDS WOULD GET
A SMALLER DOSE THAN KIDS WHO ARE
12 AND OLDER, EVEN THOUGH THEY
ARE CLOSE IN AGE AND COULD HAVE
MUCH BIGGER BODY SIZES.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO PARENTS?
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
>> NO, ACTUALLY I DON'T.
YOUR HAVE TO MAKE A CUT OFF SOME
POINT AND THE CUT OFF WAS MADE
AT THAT AGE FROM 5 TO 11.
AS YOU KNOW, FROM 12 AND OLDER,
THE DOSE WAS THE STANDARD DOSE.
THEY CUT THE DOSE DOWN NOW TO
ABOUT ONE-THIRD OF WHAT IT IS.
IT WAS 30 MICRO GRAMS AND IT'S
NOW 10.
THAT'S A REASONABLE THING TO DO.
IF YOU HAVE TO START MEASURING
IT BY BODY WEIGHT AND THINGS
LIKE THAT, IT WOULD BECOME TOO
CONFUSING.
I DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERN AS A
PHYSICIAN AND AS AN IMMUNOLOGIST
KNOWING THE KINDS OF THINGS WHEN
YOU STIMULATE THE IMMUNE SYSTEM.
I THINK WE'LL BE OKAY.
I THINK THAT WAS A PRUDENT
CHOICE.
>> THAT WAS MY QUESTION ABOUT
BODY MASS AND SIZE AND HEIGHT
AND YOU DON'T FIND THAT
NECESSARY?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO, DON.
I DON'T.
I THINK IT WOULD BECOME TOO
CONFUSING IF THAT WERE THE CASE.
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD WAY TO
HAVE THE CUTOFF.
>> LISTEN, A RECENT KAISER
FAMILY FOUNDATION POLL SHOWS
AROUND ONE-THIRD OF PARENTS OF 5
TO 11-YEAR-OLDS WILL VACCINATE
THEIR CHILDREN AS SOON AS IT'S
AVAILABLE.
WITH COVID TRENDING DOWN RIGHT
NOW AND CASES OFTENLESS SEVERE
IN CHILDREN, LOTS OF PARENTS ARE
ASKING IF THEIR KIDS REALLY NEED
IT.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THEM?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK THE ANSWER
TO THAT, AS I FEEL FAIRLY
CERTAIN THE ANSWER TO THAT IS IT
WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA TO
VACCINATE THE CHILDREN.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU ASK PEOPLE
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE LIKELIHOOD OF
HAVING VACCINATIONS BE THERE FOR
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY'RE ADULTS
OR CHILDREN, WE START OFF AROUND
35, 37% AND THEN WHEN PEOPLE
START SEEING THAT THE
VACCINATIONS ARE BEING
DISTRIBUTED AND THEY'RE BEING
ADMINISTERED AND THINGS ARE
GOING WELL, PEOPLE GAIN MORE
CONFIDENCE.
SO I THINK THAT NUMBER OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE WILLING IF
NOT ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT GETTING
THEIR CHILDREN VACCINATED IS
GOING TO INCREASE.
YOU KNOW, DON, I DO FEEL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO VACCINATE CHILDREN.
NO DOUBT FROM THE STATISTICAL
STANDPOINT WHEN CHILDREN GET
INFECTED, THERE'S VERY MUCH MORE
LIKELY THAT THEY WOULD NOT HAVE
A SEVERE OUTCOME COMPARED TO AN
ELDERLY PERSON LIKE MYSELF OR
SOMEONE WHO HAS AN UNDERLYING
CONDITION.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE
KIDS ARE EXEMPT FROM SOME
SERIOUS ILLNESS BECAUSE ALL YOU
NEED TO DO IS GO TO THE
PEDIATRIC HOSPITALS AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND YOU SEE PARTICULARLY
WITH THE DELTA VARIANT, WHICH
HAS A MUCH GREATER CHANCE OF
TRANSMITTING THAT MORE KIDS ARE
GETTING INFECTED AND AS MORE
KIDS GET INFECTED, SOME OF THEM,
MAYBE A SMALL PROPORTION ARE
GOING TO HAVE A SERIOUS OUTCOME.
ALSO, YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DON'T HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
THE CHILDREN INADVERTENTLY AND
INNOCENTLY WHEN THEY GET
INFECTED, MANY OF THEM WITHOUT
ANY SYMPTOMS ARE SPREADING IT
WITHIN THE FAMILY UNIT, WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT RECENT STUDIES
INDICATE THAT THAT MIGHT BE THE
CASE.
THERE IS A REALLY GOOD REASON TO
HAVE THE CHILDREN VACCINATED AND
THAT'S THE REASON WHY WE HOPE
THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO ANSWER THE
REASONABLE QUESTIONS THAT
PARENTS WOULD HAVE AND NO DOUBT
ABOUT THAT, THEY HAVE GOOD
QUESTIONS AND HOPEFULLY, IN THE
OUT REACH WE'LL BE ABLE TO
ADEQUATELY ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
OF THE PARENTS.
>> ONE OF THOSE REASONABLE
QUESTIONS MIGHT BE, YOU KNOW, MY
KID ALREADY HAD COVID.
THEY STILL NEED TO GET THE
VACCINE?
I MEAN, I KNOW YOU RECOMMEND IT
FOR ADULTS.
IS THAT THE SAME FOR KIDS AS
ADULTS, DO THEY STILL NEED THE
VACCINE?
>> I THINK THAT WOULD BE THE
CASE FOR THE FOLLOWING REASON.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS SO
CLEAR IF YOU ARE INFECTED AND
RECOVER AND THEN YOU GET
VACCINATED, THE LEVEL OF YOUR
IMMUNITY AGAINST REINFECTION IS
REALLY PROFOUND.
IT GOES WAY, WAY UP MAKING YOU
REALLY VERY, VERY WELL PROTECTED
AGAINST A RETURN INFECTION EVEN
WITH A DIFFERENT VARIANT BECAUSE
WE KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE A HIGH
LEVEL OF THESE NEUTRALIZING
ANTIBODIES, IT SPILLS OVER AND
COVERS ESSENTIALLY MANY OF THE
VARIANTS THAT WE KNOW ARE
CIRCULATING.
RIGHT NOW, DELTA IS OBVIOUSLY
THE CRITICAL ONE.
IT OCCUPIES ABOUT 99% OF THE
ISOLATES IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> SO OTHER QUESTIONS.
PARENTS ARE WORRIED ABOUT MISC
AND LONG COVID IN CHILDREN.
HOW MUCH DO WE HAVE TO LEARN
MORE THAN A YEAR AND A HALF INTO
THIS, DOCTOR?
>> WE KNOW IT OCCURS AND IT'S
SERIOUS.
THERE ARE SOMETHING LIKE 5,000
KIDS THAT WE HAVE DOCUMENTED
HAVE GOTTEN MISC.
LONG COVID IS AN INTERESTING
THING, DON.
THE REASON IS THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE LEARN ABOUT IN
REALTIME AS THE MONTHS GO BY AND
MAYBE EVEN THE YEARS GO BY, IS
THAT WE DON'T KNOW THE FULL
IMPACT OF WHAT HAPPENS FOLLOWING
INFECTION.
WE'RE LEARNING A LOT ABOUT THAT.
WE KNOW THAT KIDS CAN GET LONG
COVID AND FOR THE AUDIENCE NOT
KNOWING WHAT THAT IS, IT'S A
PERSISTENCE OF SYMPTOMOLOGY
SOMETIMES NOT REALLY READILY
EXPLAINED BY ANY PATHOLOGY
PROCESS BUT WE'VE SEEN IT CAN BE
DEBILITATING IN ADULTS.
FORTUNATELY, CHILDREN
STATISTICALLY HAVE A LESS OF A
CHANCE OF LONG COVID I THINK
THAN ADULTS.
IT'S ANYWHERE FROM 5 TO 10 TO
30% OR MORE.
WITH CHILDREN IT'S BETWEEN 4 AND
6%.
BUT THERE IS STILL THE RISK AND
YOU DON'T WANT TO TAKE THE
CHANCE OF A CHILD HAVING SOME
LONG TERM CONSEQUENCES OF BEING,
FEELING WASHED OUT, INABILITY TO
CONCENTRATE AND THE THINGS THAT
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH LONG COVID.
A LOT OF REASONS, DON, TO GET
THE CHILDREN VACCINATED.
>> YOU KNOW, I DID A STORY LAST
NIGHT.
I REPORTED LAST NIGHT ABOUT A
HIGH SCHOOL THAT IS TESTING
WHETHER SOME OF THE KIDS CAN --
KIDS AND STAFF VACCINATED, IF
THEY CAN GO MASKLESS.
SO MANY PARENTS WANT TO KNOW IF
THEIR KIDS WILL BE ABLE TO GO
MASKLESS ONCE THEY ARE
VACCINATED.
>> YOU KNOW, THE ANSWER IS NOT
RIGHT NOW.
WHEN YOU SAY MASKLESS, I THINK
DON, WE HAVE TO QUALIFY WHAT YOU
MEAN.
IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IN AN
INDOOR SPACE IN WHICH YOU'RE NOT
SURE EVERYONE IS VACCINATED OR
WHAT THEIR STATUS IS, THE CDC
RECOMMENDATION STILL SAYS THAT
IN THE SCHOOL SETTING AND INDOOR
CONGREGATE PLACES TO WEAR A
MASK, EVEN WHEN VACCINATED AND
THE REASON IS, DON, THE DYNAMICS
OF INFECTION RIGHT NOW WE STILL
ARE AVERAGING ABOUT 70,000
INFECTIONS A
ISOLATE
THAT'S A VIRAL DYNAMIC THAT'S
TOO HIGH.
WE DON'T NEED TO DO ANY MORE
MITIGATION.
THERE WILL BE A TIME WE CAN PUT
THE MASKS BEHIND US.
I DON'T BELIEVE NOW,
PARTICULARLY IN AN INDOOR
SETTING THAT WE'RE READY FOR
THAT RIGHT NOW.
>> I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
RIGHT NOW, I'M SURE YOU KNOW,
DR. DEBORAH BIRX GAVE A
RESPONSE, SAYING 135,000 LIVES
COULD HAVE BEEN SAVED BY I WANT
-- IMPLEMENTING MASKS AND SHE
SAYS THAT THE 2020 ELECTION
DISTRACTED THEM FROM THE VIRUS
RESPONSE.
YOU WERE THERE, DO YOU AGREE
WITH HER CHARACTERIZATION?
>> I THINK WE COULD HAVE DONE
MUCH BETTER, AND I MADE NO
SECRET ABOUT THAT.
THAT GOT ME INTO SOME TROUBLE
WITH THE TRUMP PEOPLE WHEN I WAS
BEING OPEN AND HONEST ABOUT THE
FACT THAT I FELT THAT MANY OF
THE THINGS THAT WERE SAID ABOUT
DON'T WORRY THIS IS GOING TO GO
AWAY OR NOT PAYING AS MUCH
ATTENTION TO IT, I DON'T THINK
YOU COULD PUT A NUMBER ON HOW
MANY LIVES WOULD HAVE BEEN SAVED
IF YOU DID IT DIFFERENTLY.
IT'S MUCH EASIER THE OTHER WAY
TO SAY IF YOU DID THIS DIFFERENT
THING, IF YOU VACCINATED PEOPLE,
YOU WOULD IN FACT SAVE A LOT OF
LIVES.
YOU KNOW, DR. BIRX TRIED HER
BEST WHEN SHE WAS THERE, I WAS
WITH HER, BUT A LOT OF TIMES
SOME OF THE THINGS WE
RECOMMENDED WERE NOT PUT INT